[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est avec vous on est
en direct c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue notamment sur cette
nouvelle charte qui a été signé
notamment à l'elysée lundi dernier ce
lundi est-ce que ce yacht que doivent
signer que devrait signer en tous les
cas les imams français est ce que vous
l'approuvez est ce que vous y croyez on
attend vos points de vue en attend ce
soir celui de philippe meyer bonsoy
philippon soirée bonne année merci oui
bonne année à tous et tous ceux qui nous
écoutent animateurs fonde alors qu'il
nous écoute ici sur le site du figaro
bien qui vous écoute sur le site du
nouvel esprit public puisque vous en est
l'animateur le fondateur l'âme à
retrouver sur le web site du nouvel
esprit public offre un avantage c'est
qu'on me voit pas et on regrette
beaucoup d'ailleurs le dernier
enregistrement en ligne en tout cas est
consacrée au vaccin contre la colline et
au départ d'angola merkel face à vous ce
soir alexis brézet directeur des
rédactions du figaro bonsoir avec bonsoy
ben ça alors le figaro qui revient dans
les prochaines heures bien sûr sur
l'investiture de joe biden est également
ces dernières heures vous revenez à
travers une interview passionnante de
jean luis borges sur le débat autour du
rétablissement ou non de la
proportionnelle en tous les cas d'une
dose de proportionnelle
c'était une promesse d' emmanuel macron
c'est maintenant ou jamais c'est plus
que jamais menacée alors faut-il y aller
faut-il renoncer
on en débat ce soir mais d'abord aucune
conviction religieuse ne peut être
invoqué pour se soustraire aux
obligations des citoyens c'est ce qui
est inscrit en préambule de la nouvelle
charte sur les principes de l'islam en
france
l'article 6 notamment rejette toute
forme d'ingérence étrangère et
d'instrumentalisation de l'islam à des
fins politiques
alors certaines voix s'élèvent et parle
d'un texte anti musulmans réponse ou
réplique plus exactement du président du
conseil français du culte musulman est
proche autrefois des frères musulmans
mohammed moussaoui non ce n'est pas un
texte aussi musulman il ya certainement
des mesures
qui permettront de combattre
l'extrémisme se réclamant de l'islam est
une religion est évident que ces mesures
puissent x6 être étudié par les députés
alors alexis ni nos convictions
religieuses ni toute autre raison ne
saurait supplanter les principes qui
fondent le droit et la constitution de
la république c'est ce qu'on peut lire
dans ce dans ce texte dans tous les cas
si j'en crois jean marie guénois qui
revient longuement sur la question ce
matin et plus loin les images ne peuvent
les imams pardon ne peuvent pas faire
valoir en france un traitement
différencié pour les musulmans est ce
que dans ce texte on va dans un sens
souhaitable pour vous
je pense que le texte en tant que tel
oui il va plutôt dans le bon sens c'est
quand même plutôt une bonne surprise
mais on va y revenir
qu'un certain nombre de fédérations
musulmanes est pas tout est accepté de
signer ce texte ya certains utilisent
les éléments vous ne venez de dire après
il faut regarder dans le détail parce
qu'évidemment tout ça c'est de l'exégèse
donc quand on vous dit il yal égale
dignité hommes et femmes
il sait très bien de qualité mais de la
dignité de la femme peut-être peut être
d'être soumise peu de portée et
peut-être de porter un voile peut-être
de et donc vous dire c'est sa dignité
d'être soumise et de porter un voile et
donc quand donc il faut pas non plus
crier du temps mais n'empêche que le
fait que ce document soit signé ça va
plutôt dans le bon sens après les
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
d'abord sur le fait qu'il n'était signé
que par cinq fédérations sur sur neuf et
surtout surtout sur le fait que la
question que vous souhaitez qui est
représenté par tous ces braves gens qui
ont signé ce texte il ya en france en
gros deux mille cinq cents mosquées
on sait déjà qu'un à 1500 qui ne dépend
pas du tout du cn en aucune façon et que
quand aux mille autres elles ne sont pas
forcément ceux soumise à une juridiction
ça ne sont pas soumises les juridictions
hiérarchique c'est pas parce que
monsieur moussaoui pour une partie où le
recteur de la mosquée de paris pour une
autre parti ou un autre pour une
troisième partie aurait signé que
certaines les autres imams par exemple
suite la mosquée de lyon d'où moi j'ai
rien n'aurait que ça on va pas consulté
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
donc ça va être encore très très
compliqué il vaut mieux malgré tout un
pas dans ce sens là qu'un pas dans
l'autre sens en soi
est ce que vous partagez les
appréhensions d'alexis oui sur le
satisfaction de principe oui c'est une
pierre sur une petite pierre avec les
problèmes qu alexis viennent dire et
même à l'intérieur de ce qu'ils ont
signé on a l'impression que c'est un peu
comme les pères conciliaires avec qui
dans la religion catholique quand on les
interroge ils ont trois réponses
possibles placette ça me va notre place
est ça ne vend pas et plaçait de juxta
modo hockey ça me va mais pas tous ne me
va pas de la même manière
maintenant la liste qui a été faite
j'ajoute à celle d'alexis le l'absence
de condamnation pour orientation
sexuelle de la condamnation de la
misogynie le droit à l'apostasié
tout ça sent quand même des choses vues
de contrôle en terre d'islam et l'entrée
dans l'industrie meti tout ça est écrit
dans un français tout à fait limpide ce
qu'ils méritent aussi d'être souligné
parce que quelquefois c'est écrit dans
un thème dans un tel charabia qu'on ne
sait pas très bien à quoi s'engage les
gens qui ont signé là c'est pas le cas
c'est écrit dans un français limpide et
en même temps c'est quelque chose qui
sera opposable pas opposable
hiérarchiquement comme alexis l'a
souligné il n'y a pas de hiérarchie chez
les musulmans mais qui sera opposable je
dirais politiquement dans le sens le
plus large du mot politique
quant à ceux qui voient dans ce texte
une manifestation anti musulmane je ne
sais pas quels lieux ils ont mais je
n'arrive pas à trouver quoi que ce soit
qui puisse être interprété dans ce sens
il n'y a aucune espèce mot pendant un
mot qu est sûre abondamment utilisé n'y
a aucune espèce de stigmatisation dia au
contraire me semble-t-il le fait que
alors bien sûr qu'il ya une pression du
président de la république une pression
mais
pourquoi pas cette pression s'exerce
dans un sens convenable il n'y a aucune
raison de s'en plaindre
et il me semble qu'il ya dans ce texte
quelque chose qu'on est d'autant plus
content de lire que on peut aussi se
demander ce qui se serait passé si de
toutes ces réunions il était sorti rien
c'est pas passé loin
c'est pas passé loin après en effet même
l'imam de bordeaux par exemple qui est
connue pour être quelqu'un dans les
positions sont modérés et tout à fait
républicaine a dit mais il faut encore
que les théologiens se prononce il ya
des problèmes d'herméneutique et c'est
donc cette toutou ne changera pas du
jour au lendemain ni même d'un mois à
l'autre et même d'une année à l'eau mais
il ya quelque chose qui est encore une
fois peut-être opposable et qui est posé
sur la table et ceux qui refusent ce
texte devront bien un jour ou l'autre
expliquait pourquoi il le refuser mais
ce qu'ils refuseront cas rien à rien ils
revivront au nom de quelque chose de
très simple c'est le camp se dire que
c'est ça la vraie difficulté c'est qu'à
part des mois au lieu de corentin textes
sacrés inaccessible l'interprétation eux
il y aura évidemment des imams et des
fidèles musulmans pour dire non mais ce
truc là est un chiffon de papier qu'ils
y auraient été extorqués d'ailleurs
quand on est forcé de signer en islam la
droite signé tout ce qu'on nous force à
signer peu importe la vérité du moment
que ici s'il faut le faire vous le
permet on n'est pas engagée par par
pantxo de la forme de tak et à la
dissimulation eux me dire oh mais c'est
pas c'est parce que dans le corps le
coran dit que le mécréant d'apostât un
mérite la condamnation à mort à nous
pour nous raconter tout ce que vous
voulez on vous croit pas et le risque
jeu après on verra quelles proportions
salbris ses quinze membres de d'imams
disent attention les imams qui ont signé
ça c'est un peu l'équivalent des prêtres
jure heures sur leur évolution qui avait
si j'ai signé la constitution civile du
clergé qui était donc considérée
comme des sacrilèges et et ça il y aura
ça il y aura un certain évidemment
semble d'imams un certain nombre de
fidèles musulmans qui diront nous ne
sommes pas contre lié par cette affaire
là la question est celle de la
proportion et c'est vrai que la question
du de la pression politique peut avoir
son importance dans cette dialectique là
je suis pas complètement d'accord la
borne l'accompagnent sont les prêtres
jure heures les prêtres joueurs il n'y
avait pas de fondement dans l'évangile
pour jurer ou pompe pas juriste une
question disciplinaire à l'intérieur de
la réalisation de l'église et l'autre
chose c'est qu'il me semble que l'un des
avantages de ce texte c'est que par
rapport à ces imams qui diront mais
aulas dont le corps on dit tout à fait
autre chose
le texte repousse un peu le débat à
l'intérieur du monde musulman
plutôt que ce soit toujours de l'autre à
l'extérieur longtemps ce qui est
souhaitée depuis longtemps par un
certain nombre de personnes qui disent
que il eu le doigt avant un débat à
l'intérieur de l'islam pour pouvoir se
réformer oui et je pense que c'est une
bonne chose que ce texte existe parce
que encore une fois il met la balle dans
la partie musulmane ou lieu qui est
toujours à l'extérieur des gens qu'ils
arrimer la république elle république
elle dit que mon et prier à l'école de
considérer l'enseignement comme
l'enseignement qui doit être suivie et a
pris et non pas que la terre est plate
ou dire c'est que voilà non mais ce
n'est pas pour nier l'intérêt de ce
texte c'est de dire que son application
va être très difficile très
problématique très partiel probablement
et que ceux qui refuseront ce texte
auront certainement des arguments
valides
d'un point de vue religieux pour dire
nous ne sommes pas liés de toute façon
aucun musulman et aucun imam n'est lié
par la décision d'un autre imam puisqu'à
pas dire archi écrivons nous on n'est
pas lié par sa donc après faut expier
espérer que la pédagogie la pl fera son
oeuvre que le temps fera son oeuvre bon
mais enfin c'est pas cet effort est
quand même très très loin d'être gagné
mais on n'a pas encore évoqué tous ceux
des imams qui dépendent notamment pour
leur subsistance d'un pays étrangers
notamment ceux qui dépendent des turcs
mais aussi ceux qui n'ont rien signé
qu'il est facile is pas d'ingérence mais
financer des pas géants ce nom alors bon
donc ils seront financés
une fois qu'ils seront financés les uns
par les airs germe les autres par les
marocains même si eux disent non pour
nous ça n'est pas de l'ingérence et
simplement du soutien la fois on veut
pas dire que soutenir la fois deux de
ses compatriotes c'est de l'ingérence
n'empêche que il y aura pas maintenir
donc en fait c'est comme toujours entre
ba n cotation bah oui enfin comment dire
l'intervention même de la constitution
fin de tout ça suppose un consensus et
une bonne volonté de part et d'autre
pour appliquer un texte si les gens qui
ont signé textes ne sont pas désignés je
ne dis pas qu'ils me sont tous ne le
sont pas mais s'ils ne le sont pas il ya
toujours une bonne façon de l'expliquer
pour dire non non non ça n'est pas de de
l'homophobie que de condamner très
fortement l'homosexualité non c'est pas
d'homophobie
depuis il ya mille façons de dire les
choses et il semble enfin en tout cas je
crois que plusieurs analystes sont
d'accord pour dire que l'horrible
assassinat samuel patty a joué un rôle
dans le fait que ceux qui ont signé en
signe et je pense aussi que ça met en
lumière quelque chose c'est que tout ce
travail de dentelle ce long travail ce
très long travail qui peut s'appuyer sur
ce texte repose maintenant dans une
extrêmement grande partie sur
l'éducation nationale et que sur ce plan
là il va falloir que les autorités de
l'éducation nationale le ministre mais
pas seulement se prononce sur une façon
de faire comprendre ce au nom de quoi
cette charte a été signée ou aux jeunes
élèves et aux lycéens dont un certain
nombre d'entre nous le savons nous le
savons par des publications récentes
sont hostiles à la théorie de
l'évolution par exemple etc etc
je ne sais pas si les spectateurs
d'entendre nous sommes cernés de
langlade avec l'aller
nous gardons récent froid absolument up
a demandé au directeur technique de
veiller de pouvoir et de nous répondre
aux besoins des éléments des bougies
dans tous les cas pour l'instant on est
reçu sur le site c'est l'essentiel et
vous êtes en train de nous poser des
questions
justement peut-être y répondre celle de
christophe qui nous dit est ce la fin
des revendications religieuses comme les
horaires différencier hommes et femmes
dans les piscines
j'ai envie de répondre à christoph en
théorie oui quand on lit ce texte est ce
que c'est votre point de vue je crois
pas vous verrez que même avant en
interprétant comme il faut ce texte on
pourra toujours trouver que ce qu'en
fait ce que c'est pas qu'on peut avoir
un traitement différencié
quel est le mot l'acea traitement est ce
que un traitement différencié entre
hommes et femmes dans les piscines
non mais le mode dans le texte qui dit
pas complètement différent des lots dans
ce dossier pour les musulmans au combat
on dira qu'il faut que c'est pas que
pour les musulmans mais c'est simplement
pour les hommes pour les femmes et que
et c'est pas pour les musulmans hommes
et pour les musulmans femmes on accepte
des non musulmans dans l'est avec les
hommes et les moins donc j'ai demandé
que les femmes
vous voyez que ce traitement différencié
que je réclame n'est pas un traitement
pour les musulmans c'est simplement pour
les enfants la différence libre mais
comment dire ses textes à les mérites et
les faiblesses deux cas toujours
l'autodiscipline par rapport à la
discipline c'est nul c'est très
sympathique notre cible c'est très
estimable mais il ya un moment il faut
aussi affirmé la discipline et donc
autant on peut souhaiter que les
musulmans s'applique même
l'autodiscipline autant il est du devoir
de l'école et des de la loi républicaine
d'affirmer la discipline c'est vrai à
l'école et on a vu que notamment que les
professeurs ou sont encore aujourd'hui y
compris propre laisse quelques semaines
après l affaire de meurtre de sa mère
pattie totalement désarmés et face à ces
revendications et qui ne savent plus
comment faire
mais pas que la question du voile quand
on nous explique qu'elle n'a rien à voir
avec le séparatisme amic puisque il faut
pas interdire le voile pour les enfants
mineurs parce que ça n'aurait rien à
voir avec le sujet du séparatisme
on se dit là si c'est ça le point de
départ
on ne comprend pas trop donc à un moment
il faut falloir affirmé attendre de
principe on ne peut pas se dire que les
choses vont uniquement de se régler par
la bonne volonté d'une des parties faut
aussi que la partie l'anneau
républicaine affirmant son nombre de
choses et les fasse respecter c'est
justement une des questions
d'internautes qui dit quid du port du
voile chez les mineurs les fillettes
notamment cela est il compatible avec la
écoutez là aussi jambes je reviens à
l'éducation nationale et je cite au
passage un livre d'un nos confrères
frédéric beague un livre qui doit avoir
maintenant deux ou trois ans qui
s'appelle une prière pour l'école qui
est un an dans quête de reportages un an
de journalisme à travers la france sur
les problèmes qui font que l'école dans
beaucoup d'endroits se défait et se
défait de manière tout à fait profonde
là encore on a vu avec après
l'assassinât de samuel paty et on l'a vu
avec d'autres professeurs qui ont comme
lui pris la parole pour expliquer ce
qu'était la caricature etc etc
sans être nécessairement des apologistes
des caricatures précise de tel ou tel
journal on a vu ce que l'appareil de
l'éducation nationale ne faisait pas
et même pire encore ce qu'il faisait
c'est à dire les lâchés en rase campagne
voire à les menacer de sanctions ça
c'est quelque chose sur quoi ça c'est
quelque chose qui relève de l'autorité
de l'éducation nationale et c'est
quelque chose sur quoi on peut terminer
on peut arrêter c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut arrêter beaucoup plus
rapidement que c'est d'obtenir cette
autodiscipline que le gouvernement
demande en étant d'ailleurs plus ou
moins fondées parce que l'autodiscipline
n'est pas exactement la ressource sur
laquelle il a le plus compté dans les
mois qui ont suivi le rire
l'épidémie de grippe il faut cantonner
cette question à l'école vous
dans vous écoutant ses c'est à l'école
tout ce que tout se joue mais j'ai
l'impression quand même que non halal et
le question du voile pour les petites
filles ce n'est pas l'école c'est une
c'est une question qu'il faut affirmer
ce principe non pas comme le dit madame
berger au nom de la laïcité il pas de
raison d'imposer la laïcité dans les
foyers
parce qu'à ce moment là à ce compte là
on va interdire la kippa interdire les
années croît dans les maisons en quoi
donc c'est pas la question de la laïcité
c'est la question de cette démo utilisé
par des associations marocaines de
violences faites aux enfants d'imposer à
des petites filles de porter un voile
il suffit de dire non ce sont des
traitements qu'on n'impose pas aux
enfants voilà point faut pas entrer dans
ces histoires il ya un moment il faut
que la république affirme ses descentes
de principe sans vouloir faire la
religion et la place des religions en
respectant leur place sans dire on va
entrer là-dedans veut pas réformer les
religions ont dit ça oui ça non ben le
voile pour les petites filles on peut
dire non c'est pas l'école ça c'est la
loi et est alors après on n'ira pas chez
les gens pour le faire respecter
en revanche dans la rue on peut le faire
respecter orient aujourd'hui des petites
villes qui sont voilées dans les rues
une autre question qui est posée passait
pas évoquer par exemple dans le set
shirt c'est pas invoqué dans cette
charte un donc je répond d'ailleurs à
qui monsieur youtube qui nous dit pouvez
nous dire en quoi consiste exactement
cette charte des imams quel est son
contenu
bah on va vous de m l'article de jean
marie guénois qui revient longuement sur
donc cette nouvelle
cette charte qui est en discussion pour
l'instant et
j'aimerais qu'on réponde à cette
question de jean-marc kindy mais il n'y
a pas besoin de chars qu'il suffit que
les musulmans obéissent à la loi
il suffit oui d'accord il suffit mumbai
aka yaka qu'est ce qu'ils attendent le
musulman pour la loi puisque c'est les
musulmans dire s'est il ya un certain
nombre de musulmans qui sont des
musulmans qui ont une interprétation de
leur religion qui fait que 10 à leurs
enfants si on te dit si on t'explique
les théories de darwin c'est pas vrai
bon il faut il faut il faudrait mais ça
ne se fait pas sans un travail
pédagogique et politique
une autre question qui est posée par el
arif qui me dit c'est quoi au juste un
islam républicain par le temps de
catholicisme républicain si on en a
parlé
je veux dire il faut quand même se
souvenir de la violence physique
la violence matérielle qui a été
déployée contre des congrégations contre
des camps qui ont été transformées
c'était pas enfin bon peut-être qu'ils
avaient dans le lit cette idée là
peut-être au moment d'être est trop cher
sinon y'a pas l'idée de faire un
catholicisme républicains s'étaient
d'imposer semble de loi au catholicisme
mais ce n'était pas de le transformer
c'est pour ça que moi je me méfie
toujours quand l'état veut transformer
les religions en revanche il est
légitime qui pose la sente de limites
après on est l'accord n'est pas d'accord
baisser des limites posées par l'état et
on fait avec et quelquefois c'est
demande une action médiatique muscles et
voilà mais c'était très musclée des
ateliers que ça mais pour autant la
religion catholique n'est pas devenue
une religion républicaine il y à des
quêtes des catholiques dans les
monarchies et des catholiques dictature
des critiques dans des républiques et
des catholiques dans des démocraties
parlementaires donc la région catholique
n'est pas républicaine pas plus que
l'islam n'a vocation être république on
leur demande de respecter aux uns et aux
autres de respecter des règles mais
c'est pas de changer la théologie c'est
pas le boulot de l'état ou 2 ou
d'adhérer telle ou telle forme de dents
banon la nouvelle charte des imams
peut-elle selon vous permettre le
développement d'un islam républicain
alors la question vous a été posée sur
twitter et vous
assez sceptique dans tout cas dans ceux
qui ont répondu puisque vous répondez
non à 79%
il ya une autre question qu'on pose sur
twitter c'est si le gouvernement doit
abandonner la proportionnelle pour les
élections législatives
c'était avant le corps un navire russe
c'était avant les gilet jaune
c'était pourtant il n'ya pas si
longtemps et c'était une promesse signé
de la part d'un certain emmanuel macron
la représentativité reste toutefois un
combat inachevé dans notre pays je
souhaite le mener avec vous résolument
je proposerai ainsi que le parlement
soit élu avec une dose de
proportionnelle pour que toutes les
sensibilités
ils soient justement représentés alors
quatre ans plus tard on n'a pas eu notre
dose et le député modem jean louis
bourlanges le regrette notamment dans
les colonnes du figaro aujourd'hui le
scrutin majoritaire intégral dit-il
notamment est inutile sous la vème
république et même il est devenu toxique
depuis l'adoption du quinquennat
il plaide pour un scripteur lui inspirer
des élections municipales mais bon il
accepterait un scrutin qu'ils soient
inspirés du modèle sénatoriales donc si
j'ai bien compris le modèle sénatoriales
c'est que dans certains départements il
est majoritaire et dans d'autres il est
proportionnel dans les départements où
il ya le plus de députés de sénateurs à
élire il est proportionnel mais là où il
n'y en a qu'un ou deux il est
majoritaire philippe ça c'est un débat
byzantin où c'est une façon de restaurer
le lien entre le peuple et ses
représentants
écoutez d'abord il ya quand même quelque
chose d'assez drôle c'est que cette
histoire de la proportionnelle olizy ou
législative c'est une variante de
l'anaphore elana forte on avait
découverte que françois hollande avait
dit moi président je ferais ceci ma
présidence je ne ferai pas cela là c'est
une forme d' hannah fort mais sauf que
chacun de ceux qui utilisent c'est une
nana fort que mon dirais-je comme au
relais 4 x 100 m c'est à dire que le
premier c'est nicolas sarkozy qui dit
moi président proportionnelle le
deuxième c'est françois hollande et du
mois président proportionnelle et le
troisième c'est emmanuel macron convient
d'entendre qu'il y moi président
proportionnelle
enfin pas de proportionnelle du tout
donc le suivant pourra reprendre le fil
de l'anaphore alors la proportionnelle
qui peut prendre un nombre de formes
c'est extrêmement compliqué davantage de
jean louis bourlanges c'est qu'ils
expliquent les choses clairement son ca
proportionnelle est clair mais la
proportionnelle est réputé rendre les
pays très difficile à gouverner voire
ingouvernable on agite le fantôme de la
quatrième république même de la
troisième des changements incessants de
formation du gouvernement s'est pas
complètement injustifiée mais est-ce que
c'est par rapport à ça qu'il faut se
prononcer moi j'aurais tendance à
vouloir me prononcer et bon l'orge et
là-dessus extrêmement claire par rapport
à la disparition la raréfaction des
actes importants du parlement et
notamment de la chambre des députés qui
est de plus en plus dépossédé de sa
fonction le déposséder toutes les
manières d'ailleurs maintenant on prend
35 type dans l'annuaire du téléphone et
on dit bon bah c'est vous qui aura des
tirages au sort alors je descends vers
la magie maxi d'un côté 35 tirés au sort
et de l'autre côté un monsieur vaccin
qui dit oh moi la logistique c'est pas
mon truc c'est dommage parce que c'est
pour ça qu'il avait été nommé mais je
passe sur ce débat je passe sur ce débat
là mais je pense que le point de vue à
partir duquel il faudrait réfléchir à la
proportionnelle et je pense à partir
lequel il faudrait instaurer une
proportionnelle puisqu'il n'y a pas une
seule proportionnelle c'est le point de
vue de l'importance du parlement
je pense que parmi les livres les plus
nécessaires à lire pour se former une
opinion c'est celui de jean françois
revel qui s'intitule l'absolutisme
inutiles et qui dont il me semble que
les récents événements autour du que
vides montre qu'en effet il est inutile
et inefficace
justement puisque philippe a soulevé un
autre prend fin une autre question qui
est pas répondu à la mienne c'est le
problème de l'ingouvernabilité et
finalement on disait que on faisait pas
trop la proportionnelle soit vème
république pour renforcer le travail de
l'exécutif jour d'avoir un mot peut-être
de là l'éventualité de cette
proportionnelle moi je n'y crois pas
pour une raison qui ne doit rien aux
questions de principe
faut juste que je viens d'évoquer qui
tient au simple au simple fait que si
d'aventuré mâcon faisait la
professionnelle le temps plus est très
content et que ça aurait comme résultat
de faire entrer à l'assemblée au bas mot
80 députés du front national 60 députés
la france a soumises et que comme toute
sa stratégie c'est de se présenter comme
le barrage l'adversaire féroce et
absolue dans un duel qui l'arrangent du
front national ça me paraît assez
compliqué de 2,2 de tenir ce discours là
et en même temps de dire le premier truc
que je fais en arrivant c'est
d'installer le front national
l'assemblée et pour de bonnes ou de
mauvaises raisons c'est pas la question
mais je ne vienne et spes d'incohérent
stratégique toit sera dire je suis je
veux empêcher le front national est
d'ailleurs une fois que je serai là il y
en aura dix fois plus que ce cas
aujourd'hui
même chose pour la france a soumise mais
ce serait pas son ennemi principal du
coup ci c'est ici mais que le face à
face avec le front national la range
c'est une chose mais pas au point de
l'avouer s'ils commencent à dire je vais
créer des députés front national a
cependant voulu dire écoute c'est
peut-être pas le meilleur moyen de se
lutter contre le front national
donc ça me paraît compliqué mais ça
c'est des questions d'opportunité
politique mais voilà pourquoi moi je ne
crois pas qu'il finira par le faire
après le débat entre propos des valeurs
postales cette vieille histoire qui
c'est toujours la même chose c'est ce
qu'il faut une majorité pour pouvoir
gouverner solide construite ou est ce
qu'il vaut mieux la diversité qui permet
de mieux représenter et il faut les deux
là je c'est vrai que le papier de
boulanger très intéressant en même temps
moyen point sur lequel je suis pas je ne
le suis pas c'est quand il dit il n'y a
plus de problème d'émiettement il ya
plus de problème d'ingouvernabilité je
ne le crois pas je crois qu'elle n'a
jamais eu autant dire que pendant
longtemps on a eu deux blocs
aujourd'hui on a une sorte d'émiettement
on le voit bien pour le premier tour on
sait qu'il y aura un candidat qui fera
25 % connectera 1% et connect sera 18-17
à grenoble fra 16 on n'a jamais eu un
tel émiettement de notre spectre
politique
alors on peut considérer que le le
président élu aura mécaniquement une
majorité c'est toujours été le cas mais
enfin bon c'est quand même de plus en
plus serré donc faut qu'il faut discuter
mais enfin il ya vrai une vraie question
de l'ingouvernabilité qui qui me
semble-t-il se pose la question que vous
posez philippe qui est celle de
l'abaissement du parlement
elle est réelle je ne vois pas bien
pourquoi le fait de mettre de la
proportionnelle permettrait de le
résoudre et scellier mais je finis je
voulais jouer je laisse la parole je
reviens à mon sens initial il ya besoin
d'une majorité et il ya besoin de
diversité pour représenter les
différentes opinions et le front
national et le mélangeant et tout le
monde c'est normal que tout le monde se
représenter il se trouve
me semble-t-il c'est une vieille thèse
qui était défendue en son temps par
carcassonne qu'on a la chance d'avoir
deux chambres moi ce que je me paraît le
bon sens même c'est à dire c'est qu'on a
une chambre pour assurer la majorité la
gouvernabilité avec une vraie majorité
importante c'est de l'anglais et une
somme qui permettrait de représenter la
diversité des opinions
comme elle représente par ailleurs la
diversité des territoires c'est le sénat
et là on aurait alors prévu peut-être
revoir appelé le rapport au train à
l'autre mais ça permettrait d' exister
vraiment le problème c'est qu'on a deux
jambes qui sont au scrutin majoritaire
dont vous avec des modalités différentes
mais en avoir une eau majoritaire et une
à la proportion alors pour le sénat
c'est moins vrai mais mais mais c'est ma
direction de liste c'est quand même
c'est dans le caractère de la
circonscription retenu pour le sénat
fait que le front national le
les écolos sont peu représentées de
foncia ne l'est pas le mélange on n'est
pas donc la diversité des opinions n'est
pas représentée alors plusieurs choses
sur le sénat encore faudrait-il qu'on le
lui ai pas rogner les ailes il accable
infiniment moins de pouvoir et à la fin
c'est toujours l'assemblée nationale sur
la proportionnelle intégrale sur les
demandes habilité non je joue je
viendrai à un exemple là dessus sur la
proportionnelle intégrale oui évidemment
c'est pas possible et c'est d'ailleurs
pas souhaitable et ça n'est pas souhaité
alors voudrais pas faire penser que jean
louis bourlanges est à lui seul la loi
et les prophètes mais l'intérêt de sa
réflexion là-dessus fait que c'est une
proportionnelle partiel si tu veux dire
qu'il le propose en faisant remarquer
que l'élection législative abouti à
donner une majorité à un candidat qui
n'a jamais plus de 25% au premier tour
et encore les après il dit quand même
que point où on en est mal il craint
qu'il n'y ait pas d'autres solutions que
la portion de l'intégrale un oui mais
sur ce plan là je le suivrai sûr il est
heureux sur l'ingouvernabilité je
voudrais rappeler un exemple historique
récent michel rocard premier ministre en
non seulement il a contre lui le
président de la république c'est à dire
qu'il n'a pas nommé les membres les plus
importants de son gouvernement ce qui
sont aux fonctions régaliennes ni à
l'intérieur ni aux affaires étrangères
ni à la justice etc
mais en plus il n'a pas de majorité et
il a pas de majorité parce que le
président de la république qui vient de
le nommer avait pendant les airs et la
campagne législative dit oh là là là
c'est beaucoup trop dangereux de donner
une majorité à quelques n'est pas sain
qu'un seul parti c'est à dire que
pendant trois ans michel rocard a dû
gouverner avec ce que du temps d'edgar
faure on appelait des majorités d'idées
avec le formidable travail qu'avait fait
pour lui et avec lui le très regretté
guy carcassonne
mais michel rocard n'a fait pendant
trois ans et il a fait des choses qui
vont de la nouvelle calédonie à la csg
c'est c'est à dire des choses qui
soulevé de fortes oppositions dans une
partie du parlement c'est possible ça
suppose en effet de travailler au corps
les parlementaires se suppose des
marchandages il faut pas raconter
d'histoires mais très bien la politique
c'est des compromis alors on peut
appeler ça
deux noms d'oiseaux où on peut se
débrouiller d'une majorité composite
étroite moi je me souviens de cette
époque où du coup quand même il fallait
négocier la moindre vous la petite voix
de bascule qui allait permettre deux et
ça a permis de faire la calédonie mais
laconi en fait en métropole tout montre
affiche est donc le sujet était pas
était pas législatif et ni voile ni son
fichage et la cci comme on l'aurait
aussi bien fait avec une vraie majorité
compact quand il s'agit de créer des
impôts il ya toujours une majorité donc
de ce point de vue ça me paraît pas
affadir que ça permettrait une majorité
d'idées permettent de créer des impôts
en france
on n'a pas besoin les majorités
impuissantes changer complètement le
mode de calcul de la chose pas du tout
on a juste rajouté un impôt indirect de
plus l'usager devra donner par la suite
et par tous ceux qui l'avaient critiqué
à contrer cette évolution
il ya aussi une question de degré je
suis évidemment d'accord que si on
intégrait une petite dose de
proportionnelle dans le scrutin
majoritaire ce qui permettrait à des des
familles de pensée qui sont très peu
représentés à l'assemblée de l'être le
front national
la france a soumis ce mandant
écologistes et d'autres partis que
sais-je encore moi ça me gênerait pas et
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose de
disproportionné
cette majorité la raim colo malgré tout
colossal avec quand on voit
effectivement le score de premier tour
de manuel macron quelque chose qui tient
un petit qui va pas donc ça serait con
ça serait cette majorité là serait
corrigée par une certaine diversité oui
mais c'est toujours une question de
degré appartement on arrive on veut
vraiment représenter la diversité des
opinions dans l'eure
dans la juste proportion de ce qu'elle
représente dans leur pays aujourd'hui si
on voulait représenter les opinions
ajuste promotions sont présents dans le
pays on aurait pas de majorité à
l'assemblée aucune puisque aujourd'hui
il ya plus d'opinions majoritaire dans
le pays
donc je faisais moi je mon sentiment
c'est quand même que c'est mieux d'avoir
une majorité
après il faut faire vivre la diversité
d'opinion alors je pense encore une fois
que la proportionnelle intégrale aboutir
à un parfait désordre et non pas à une
restauration du parlement dans sa main
dans ses pouvoirs et dans son importance
je pense que l'absence ou la très faible
représentation d'un certain nombre de
tendances et notamment du front national
au parlement est une erreur et c'est une
erreur constante de cette majorité
il faut quand même se souvenir que le
président de l'assemblée nationale
monsieur ferrand ne voulait pas que
madame le pen soit admise à la
commission des affaires étrangères
quelqu'un qui avait été la deuxième à
l'élection présidentielle qui
représentait un courant qui était à peu
près équivalent à celui du président de
la république et il a fallu la regrettée
marielle de sarnez qui viennent mourir
pour imposer à richard ferrand que
marine le pen puisse siéger
c'est d'ailleurs un petit exemple je m'y
attarde une seconde mais mon ami en
terre marielle de sarnez cette semaine
voilà quelqu'un qui a cru au
fonctionnement démocratique du parlement
et s'il suffit de lire les loges qui ont
été publiés après sa mort qui vont de
jean-luc mélenchon à marine le pen pour
savoir que le parlement peut être aussi
un endroit où des gens aussi opposé que
le son ce que je viens de citer et bien
d'autres peuvent travailler ensemble
moi je pense que c'est un message qu'il
faut pas en dévier peut-être qu'on peut
rajouter que majoritaire ou
proportionnel ça tout est mieux que le
tirage au sort de 35 gugusses pour
décider des choses en dehors du
parlement parce que là si on parle de
façon de contourner le parlement
ces paquets liées au mode de scrutin
majoritaire c'est y compris avec les
majorités pléthorique élus au scrutin
majoritaire ont fait fi du parlement
pour demander à des gars tire au sort de
décider les choses c'est invraisemblable
c'est bien pourquoi il faut aussi donner
un coup de barre dans l'autre sens parce
que au train où ça va
aura bientôt des comités théodule qui
seront tirés au sort dans l'annuaire du
téléphone failli à petit à petit qu'ils
pardonnent mais d'autant plus pouvoir
l'administration l exécutif parce que
c'est trop convaincu depuis ya pas de
suivi à 18 ans on le voit bien avec
l'histoire de du comité sur le climat et
aucun pouvoir de suivi contrairement au
parlement et à l'assemblée nationale qui
en a quand même hein donc tout ça et en
plus d'ailleurs ce comité de 35 est une
offense à la parité puisque nous ont
fait part été avec 35
il a forcément un sexe qui domine tu ne
montres absolue contre laquelle je
baylet vous attachez cette conception
ancienne qui veut qui est que de sexe
mais vous savez les choses compliquées
c'est un autre débat qu'on pourrait
peut-être autour de cette table mais
d'abord puisqu'on parlait de marielle de
sarnez ont je regarde le portrait de
guillaume tabard qui est vraiment très
intéressant et qui montre l'importance
qu'a représenté
marielle de sarnez dans la vie politique
française est largement méconnue et on
va demander alban barthélémy de le
mettre dans le tchat
en attendant je donne justement vos
points de vue on ne change pas les modes
de scrutin un an des élections nous dit
nicole la proportionnelle estime pas te
permettrait une meilleure représentation
du peuple plus besoin de proportionnelle
ironise christophe puisque macron a
inventé le tirage au sort et des
conventions citoyenne le truc et pense
comme vous que c'est le truc pense que
c'est un machin en tout cas un
marronnier et droite en danger un peu de
proportionnelle cela voudrait dire quoi
alors justement l'article 2 en fin
d'interview de jean louis bourlanges y
répond regardons ce qui se passe en
israël nous signale avec respect où il
devient impossible de trouver une
majorité pour gouverner effectivement
proportionnelle intégrale et classe
politique depuis très longtemps très
représentation très émiettée en
démocratie tout le monde doit être
présentes estime pat rien ne dit qu'on
aura une majorité lrm encore pronostics
kriss kross d'autant que la plupart
étaient des quasi inconnus il y a quatre
ans vole pas eu nous dit qu'il est tout
à fait d'accord avec vous alexis et
le philippe naudy changer des règles du
jeu juste avant une élément avoir une
élection en langage courant ça s'appelle
tricher al'inverse yanis nous dit encore
une promesse des campagnes non tenues
l'ue estime sur youtube qu'avec une
proportionnelle total macro aurait du
mal à gouverner
c'est ce que vous disiez alexis le
gouvernement doit-il abandonné la
proportionnelle pour les élections
législatives et vous répondez non à 67%
en tout cas ceux qui ont voté sur
twitter merci beaucoup de nous avoir
suivis merci d'avoir participé
demain pas de point de vue puisque ce
sera une émission spéciale pour
l'investiture de joe biden présenté par
charlotte variant et on sera bien sûr en
direct de washington notamment avec
adrien jaulmes merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis et n'oubliez pas le nouvel
esprit public c'est sur internet
[Musique]